also moralischen Narzissmus ist ein
Begriff den ich entwickelt habe weil
Narzissmus sehr bekannt ist aber dieses
dieses Phänomen des Narzissmus nämlich
dass man sich selbst idealisiert das
heißt ich bin der beste und zweitens
einmal den anderen abwerte dass es du
bist nichts wert also diese zwei
Parameter sind wichtig und das dritte
ist die selbst immer nein im Vergleich
zur selbstfahrzendenz das heißt ich
erkenne nichts Höheres an außer mich
selbst diese Haltung wird immer häufiger
besonders in der Politik und das ist
jetzt gekippt ins moralische hinein das
heißt Menschen beginnen sich besser zu
fühlen weil sie der Meinung sind dass
Ihre Meinung nicht nur richtig ist
sondern auch gut ist was du nicht willst
dass man dir tut das füge auch keinem
anderen so dann hat sie sagt ihr müsst
gut zu mir sein aber ich bin nicht gut
zu euch weil ich bin besser und genau
das ist mal reich und Narzissmus und das
kann man festmachen z.B bei den Klima
Klebern